près sur france 2
voilà monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce vendredi 7 décembre
faut-il y voir un espoir même si la
prudence est toujours de mise
l'annnonce de la création d'une zone de
rencontre phare le président uribe
apparaît comme une nouvelle étape dans
la sphère des otages retenus par les
farc en colombie
nous verrons pourquoi dans un instant
une journée marquée également par les
message radio adressé par les enfants
d'ingrid betancourt à leur mère en
france un avion de chasse de type rafale
s'est écrasé la nuit dernière en corrèze
après une chute de 4000 m le pilote
expérimenté est mort dans l'accident
une enquête a été ouverte le ministre de
la défense a souhaité très vite souligné
les qualités d'un avion qui je cite a
fait ses preuves dans l'actualité de ce
vendredi qu'une bonne nouvelle pour 46
millions de français
le taux du livret a devrait faire un
bond à 3 5%
rené hauss des armes automatiques qui
s'appliquera dès le 1er février prochain
de quoi assurer à nouveau le succès de
cette épargne la plus populaire en
france pour travailler plus il faudrait
fumée - la pause cigarette est elle
source de baisse de productivité dans
les entreprises
en attendant la difficile réforme dans
les cafés et restaurants
nous reviendrons ce soir sur les
nouvelles habitudes dans les entreprises
enfin faites vous partie des six
millions de français qui achètent un
sapin pour les fêtes de noël
nous verrons quelle somme il faudra
cette année dépensés pour s'offrir l'un
des symboles préféré pour ces fêtes de
fin d'année
on commence ce soir ce journal avec ces
dernières informations concernant la
sphère ingrid betancourt il faut bien
sûr être prudent c'est d'ailleurs le
sentiment de l'elysée ce soir mais en
colombie les positions des principales
parties au conflit semble bouger à
nouveau depuis ces dernières heures
ainsi le président uribe a annoncé la
création d'une zone de rencontre
une zone qui vous allez le voir pourrait
servir de zone des négociations avec les
farc
un nouveau pas fragile mais important
dans ce dossier on joue parfois sur les
mots mais là et peut-être aussi le prix
d'une solution dorothée olliéric c'est
dans le cadre très solennelle de l'école
de police de bogota que le président
uribe a fait et toutes dernières
déclarations
et c'est encore un coup de théâtre de la
part de cet homme qu'il y à quelques
heures encore traitait les farc de
bandits il accepte une zone de rencontre
avec les farc mais avec ces conditions
cette zone devra faire 150 kilomètres
carrés et être dans une zone rurale où
il n'ya pas de poste militaire de police
qu'il faille déplacés
en clair le président colombien fait un
geste important pour avancer dans la
négociation pour la libération des
otages mais il ne concède pas à la
guérilla ce qu'elles demandent depuis
longtemps la zone de 850 kilomètres
carrés démilitarisé autour des villes du
sud de floride à de pradera autre
précision à l'encontre de la guérilla
les partis ne devront pas être armés et
cette zone aura une durée d'existence de
seulement 30 jours
la france n'est pas directement impliqué
dans cette initiative même si en
coulisses elle reconnaît avoir eu des
contacts avec les farc
nous avons des agents qui sont entrés en
contact avec les farc et aimer c'est
évidemment une mission extrêmement
difficile parce que comme vous
l'imaginez pas entrer en contact avec
les farc
il faut marcher et ce sont des gens
remarquables qui prennent des risques
personnels donc il n'y vraiment hors de
question qu'on en dise plus sur eux
parce que dans leur cas l'anonymat est
une protection
l'objectif de cette zone de rencontre et
de mettre en place ce fameux accord
humanitaire c'est à dire les changes
entre les quarante cinq otages
politiques dont ingrid betancourt et les
500 guérilleros emprisonnés par les
autorités colombiennes et on retrouve
maintenant colombie notre correspondante
maria morales bonsoir le premier point
ce soir et que cette annonce d'une zone
de rencontre est un pas que l'on peut
qualifier d' importants effectués par le
président uribe
c'est très important c'est un pas qu'il
a franchi en colombie on n'arrivait pas
à imaginer que pour une fois le
président arrivait à les avoir une
communication directe avec les farc on
est en train de parler d'une zone de
rencontre
c'est un premier pas ils vont se
rencontrer si les farc accepte pour
commencer à dialoguer et essayer de
trouver une solution humanitaire pour la
libération d'ingrid betancourt et d
autres tâches politiques en colombie
c'est un pas extrêmement important et
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour les
familles des otages
maria désormais on a l'impression que là
balle est dans le camp des farc qui
n'ont toujours pas réagi en fait à cette
proposition
c'est ce qu'on attend ici en colombie
tout le monde est en ce moment collet
via internet pour voir quelle sera la
réponse normalement les farc ont qui
transmettent des messages s'est dit à
internet via leurs agences de presse qui
s'appelle nicole et la nouvelle en
attend on attend parce qu on dit que le
président uribe il a de son côté joué
toutes ses cartes
il a pour une fois bouger un point qu'on
trouvait inamovible et c'est du côté des
farc qu'il faut attendre et on espère on
croise les doigts en tout cas en
colombie qu'on aura une bonne nouvelle
avant noël merci maria morales une
journée également marquée par les
messages radio émis ce matin par les
deux enfants d'ingrid betancourt à leur
mère messages adressés directement
depuis les studios de nos confrères de
rfi il faut savoir que dans son poignet
en courrier ingrid betancourt avait fait
savoir à ses proches qu'il lui arrivait
de capter le canal espagnol de rfi un
lien qu'on voulu utiliser les proches de
l'otage aujourd'hui amaury guibert diane
richards et ingrid betancourt à bout de
forces
une image terrible de son lieu de
captivité l'otage franco colombienne
avait pu écrire une lettre à sa famille
un appel au secours
je n'ai plus les mêmes forces cela m'est
très difficile de continuer à croire
aujourd'hui ses enfants veulent lui
répondre son fils lorenzo était ce matin
dans le studio de radio france
internationale une édition spéciale pour
la diffusion d'un message des mots
d'amour que sa mère est susceptible
d'entendre mes mom est allé même colle à
son acquéreur cndp a été un moteur mis
en place pas la notion spécial
disparaissent il compte mais ça sent
mauvais quand à mes équipes à celle
provoquée par ce que j'ai lu aussi ont
beaucoup envie de lui dire c'était à un
moment donné que ce qu'elle veut me voir
qu'elle veut me voir vivre je veux le
savoir vivre tout savoir qu'elle enviait
je veux qu'elle manche je veux qu'elles
se nourrissent
parce que derrière derrière il ya une
mobilisation internationale qui en train
de se faire puis par téléphone depuis
new york
c'est sa soeur mais la nique
prend la parole ces messages résonneront
il dans la jungle colombienne
là où est détenu une grippe bettencourt
c'est l'espoir de ses proches un espoir
nourri par ce que disait l'otage dans sa
lettre elle écoute régulièrement la
radio tôt le matin elle se lève très tôt
à 4 heures du matin à l écoute de la
radio par terre dès 5 heures du matin et
les coudes notamment rfi et rfi ouvrira
son antenne trois fois par semaine aux
proches d'ingrid betancourt pour qu'ils
puissent envoyer d'autres messages de
soutien dans l'actualité également cet
accident encore est celui d'un avion de
combat rafale le pilote était confirmée
il effectué une mission classique
d'entraînement à 4000 mètres d'altitude
est brutalement hier en fin de journée
il a fait une chute à en piqué avant
d'exploser quelques secondes plus tard
en s'écrasant au sol à rien ne permet
d'expliquer cet accident le ministre de
la défense hervé morin s'est rendu sur
place
une enquête a été ouverte antoine gaveau
david bres des arbres sectionné ou
arrachées et derrière les experts de la
gendarmerie
un cratère profond de 4 m le rafale
s'est écrasé ici tombait à pic à plus de
900 kilomètres heure un choc d'une
violence inouïe
hier soir en pleine forêt corrézienne il
était 6 heures un car est exactement une
grande lueur s'est dégagée au moment du
crash et légendes au palacium vont tous
se diriger immédiatement sur le lieu et
c'est eux qui ont alerté les premiers
secours
objectif sauver le pilote du rafale très
vite plus de 150 militaires sont
mobilisés pour retrouver le capitaine
mort you there mais en vain cet après
midi hervé morin est venu annoncer la
mauvaise nouvelle
il n'a pas pu s'éjecter compte tenu de
la violence du choc il est fort probable
que le malheureusement que le pilote
et pénétré dans le sol directement et
que la carcasse de l'avion la cellule de
l'avion soit aujourd'hui enfouis sous la
terre
le capitaine était pourtant un pilote
chevronné qui connaissait très bien
cette zone
pour le moment on ne sait rien des
causes de l'accident et l'enquêté
s'annonce longue
les débris de l'avion pulvérisé jonchent
le sol sur plusieurs centaines de mètres
donc des moyens de levage et de fouilles
d'engins lourds vont être réquisitionnés
pour permettre de déterminer si les
réacteurs si les boîtes noires est au
fond du cratère l'accident est aussi un
nouveau coup dur pour rafal mise en
service en 2006 le biréacteur se vend
très peu c'est son premier crash
même si l'avion est exceptionnel même si
l'avion a toutes les qualités il y as
forcément chaque année tant dans l'âme
est clair que que dans l'aéronavale des
accidents les obsèques du capitaine mort
user auront lieu la semaine prochaine à
sa base de saint dizier en présence du
ministre de la défense
et cet accident intervient alors que le
président kadhafi est attendu en france
dès lundi la libye qui pourrait se
porter acquéreur de 10 à 14 appareils de
combat du type rafale un avion militaire
français qui n'a toujours pas été
exportés les suites de l'enquêté sur la
sphère du colis piégé qui a coûté la vie
à une personne et qui en a blessé
gravement une autre hier dans un cabinet
d'avocats parisien un homme avait été
placé aujourd'hui en garde à vue au 36
quai des orfèvres une première piste qui
n'a apparemment rien donné puisque celui
ci devrait être remis ce soir en en
liberté explications audrey goutard
guillaume michel autour de la scène de
crime la police scientifique était cet
après midi à la recherche du moindre
indice
les enquêteurs tentent notamment de
déterminer la force de l'explosion qui a
coûté la vie à jacqueline ben bouali et
grièvement blessé un avocat maître
branne les policiers de la brigade
criminelle ont également entendu les
témoins de l'attentât rien scénario des
faits commencent à se dessiner
hier en début d'après-midi un coursier
se présentent aux 52 boulevard
malesherbes
selon deux témoins ce serait une jeune
femme portant un casque
le motard mon au quatrième étage où se
trouve le cabinet gouët janselme c'est
la secrétaire qui l'accueille à ses
côtés se trouve m branne
la suite est racontée par cet avocat du
cabinet
normalement mais mon assistante n'aurait
pas dû ouvrir le le colis s'il ne lui
avait pas demandé comme ça parce qu'ils
étaient camarades et donc comme c'était
un cadeau il a dû lui dire où voilà
voilà pourtant que ses cheveux elle a
ouvert il ya des morts c'est vraiment
baissé pour cet avocat l'attentât est un
mystère voici m bran que l'on voit
présenter ses bureaux dans un film
promotionnel
selon ses associés il ne traitaient
aucun dossier sensible
le cabinet gère des affaires
immobilières et civils y compris à
l'international
de source policière on ne peut dire qui
était visé les enquêteurs n'ont pu
reconstituer d'étiquette sur le colis
piégés l'avocat blessé est le seul
témoin direct du drame mais son état de
santé ne permettait pas son audition
hier soir un homme a été placé en garde
à vue il ya plusieurs années il avait
été accusé d'avoir harcelé une des
associés mais finalement il a été mis
hors de cause dans l'explosion d'hier
pour le moment les policiers ne
privilégie aucune hypothèse
ils continuent de fouiller dans la vie
de chacun des cinq avocats du cabinet
économie 46 millions de français sont
concernés par cette information 46
millions c'est le nombre de livrets à en
france c'est impressionnant et c'est
tout simplement le produit d'épargné le
plus populaire du pays
et bien son taux de rémunération
pourrait atteindre dès le 1er février
entre 3,5 et 3,75 pour cent
une bonne nouvelle certes mais qui
mérite comme souvent quelques bémols
fabien shadow sylvain gauthier le livret
a aussi rentable que l'assurance vie
ce sera peut-être le cas à partir du 1er
février
de quoi redonner le moral aux 46
millions de français qui détiennent un
livret
au moment où les gens besoin d'argent
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour une fois
où ça monte aussi eu de pourcentage
aussi important c'est très bien c'est un
petit plus c'est vraiment un tout petit
plus parce que compte tenu de
l'augmentation des loyers et des légumes
et de l'essence l'augmentation du livret
a ne va rien si le taux de rémunération
passe de 3 à 3,75 pour cent en plaçant
le maximum soit quinze mille trois cents
euros
l'épargnant aura gagné 115 euros de plus
par an mais la médaille a son revers
l'argent des livret a est destiné au
logement social
une hausse des taux serait mécaniquement
répercuter sur les emprunts faits par
les offices hlm pour construire des
logements
or en ce moment nous avons un effort
très important de constructions
nouvelles affaires pour répondre aux
besoins
si cette hausse est effective il peut y
avoir une difficulté et nous allons
demander au gouvernement de voir avec
nous comment on peut essayer de s'en
sortir
l'augmentation aura bien lieu vers fils
a confirmé aujourd'hui
reste à savoir de combien l'économie
toujours avec ces annonces faites par
nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui aux petites
et moyennes entreprises en déplacement
devant le congrès de la cgpme à lyon le
président de république et annoncé la
suppression d'un impôt l'imposition
forfaitaire annuelle à partir de 2009 un
impôt qui doit être payée par les
entreprises même en l'absence de
bénéfices les interrogations toujours
autour d'une éventuelle grève dans les
transports pourquoi tout d'abord c'est
la question que se pose le ministre du
travail xavier bertrand pour qui les
négociations sont en cours avec quelles
conséquences sur le trafic
c'est la question que se posent les
usagers et où sont les propositions
nouvelles c'est la raison invoquée cette
fois par la cgt sncf et ratp pour
justifier cette nouvelle réaction
le point sur tout cela avec sophie brune
et mattioni veine le ski
y aura-t-il une grève à la sncf les
syndicats de cheminots ne semble pas en
mesure aujourd'hui de répondre à cette
question
hier pourtant la cgt annoncé une grève
menée par six syndicats aujourd'hui plus
vraiment où l'objectif c'est de
rassembler le plus grand monde s'il doit
y avoir une action ses portes sur une
action au minimum c'est d'avoir le
maximum de gens dans l'action et à
l'heure actuelle
vous savez l'unité c'est ces pauvres
toujours facile pas facile d'abord de se
mettre d'accord sur la date la cgt
souhaite lancer la grève rapidement pour
peser sur les négociations
la cfdt préfère attendre qu'elle soit
finie mais dans une phase de négociation
si la négociation soit soient leurs
ébats effectivement où on pourrait on
pourrait donc le vin de maintenir notre
avis ensuite si les syndicats divergent
sur la durée de cet arrêt de travail 59
minutes pour la cfdt 24 heures pour la
cgt un mouvement illimité pour d'autres
une grève de 24 heures ça va faire une
journée de paye de perdus pour pas grand
chose au niveau on dire du résultat
notre fédération a proposé à l'ensemble
des responsabilités un préavis
reconductible bon à cette étape nous
n'avons pas d'accord entre nous alors
grève ou pas grève le préavis n'est pas
encore déposé
mais le ministre du travail déjà
indignés français ne comprennent pas ils
comprennent pas qu'après avoir eu une
journée de grève en octobre après avoir
eu neuf à dix jours de grève en novembre
alors que les négociations d'entreprise
se sont ouvertes alors qu'on a voulu
vraiment dialoguer cours commence une
journée de grève à la ratp un préavis a
été déposé pour le 12 décembre 2001 par
la cgt
le trafic qui devrait donc être moins
perturbé qu'en novembre une bataille
financière est annoncée dans la sphère
des patients surirradiés d'epinal une
centaine de plaintes on le sait ont été
déposées et le coût pour les assurances
pourrait atteindre plusieurs millions
d'euros une procédure judiciaire est en
cours donc mais la ministre de la santé
roselyne bachelot a assuré que l'état
versera à 500 victimes une provision
exceptionnelle une réponse aux lenteurs
que l'association des victimes
dénoncé il ya quelques jours stéphanie
la fuente jean-pierre pasteur après des
mois de combats les sur irradiés
d'epinal ont finalement été entendus
ce matin le préfet des vosges l'heure à
confirmer une nouvelle que la plupart
avaient déjà lu ou entendu une avance de
dix mille euros sera versée aux 500
patients qui ont été exposés à une
surdose de rayon supérieure ou égale à
7%
cette provision n'empêchera pas la suite
des poursuites judiciaires
mais quelques jours avant noël le geste
est apprécié qu logiquement c'est très
important parce qu'enfin enfin on est
reconnu voilà c'est notre cette victime
c'est le mans jean-claude très très
fréquemment pardonnez moi mais c'est
vraiment un statut auquel nous tenons
tous pour quelque part que ça soit une
forme entre guillemets une forme de
thérapie
hasard du calendrier au même moment à
nancy le conseil de l'ordre des médecins
entendez les deux radiothérapeute tous
deux réfute l'erreur médicale leurs
prescriptions été bonne selon l'ofs
ce sont les réglages du radiophysiciens
qui sont à l'origine du mauvais dosage
quant au suivi des patients si les deux
chefs de service ne les ont pas informés
des risques encourus
c'était pour ne pas les alarmes et
informé d'une manière abrupte
quelqu'un disant veau et fait l'objet
d'une radiation vous pouvez déclencher
des conséquences peut générer un trouble
complémentaires grave sur le plan même
simplement psychologique de nature à
altérer l'état de santé des personnes
les médecins risque que la radiation la
décision du conseil de l'ordre sera
rendu le 1er février mais les
radiothérapeutes n'en ont pas fini avec
les audiences car aujourd'hui ils font
déjà plus de 100 surirradiés à avoir
porté plainte dans cette affaire justice
toujours avec le verdict qui devrait
tomber dans un instant dans le procès de
la sphère de mama galedou six jeunes
tous mineurs au moment des faits
comparaissent des peines de cinq à
quinze ans de réclusion ont été requises
par le procureur 15 ans soit la peine
maximale contre les deux jeunes qui ont
reconnu avoir mis le feu au bus le 28
octobre 2006 à marseille
autre procès et autres verdict attendu
aujourd'hui celui du meurtrier du petit
mathias et bien la cour d'assises de la
nièvre a suivi les réquisitions et
condamné christian beaulieu 57 ans à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité sur
place fang gêne au dos et laurent
déboires encadré par les policiers est
protégé par une tenue par balles
christian beaulieu tic le tribunal de
nevers sous les insultes d'un membre de
la famille du petit mathieu
on à gognies transition beaulieu vient
d'être reconnu coupable du viol et du
meurtre du petit garçon il est condamné
à la prison à perpétuité assortie d'une
période de sûreté de 30 ans c'est le
maximum qu'autorise la loi française
dans la salle la mère de l'enfant se
recueille en larmes
les cinq jours du procès ont été très
éprouvants sa ramènera pas ma tasse mais
on est satisfait on a revécu la sacem
match comme si on y était au monument
le mi6 donc là on est épuisés lessivé
cette semaine et on aura encore moins
des mois et des années pour se
reconstruire
la fin d'un cauchemar commencé le 7 mai
2006 matthias 4 ans est retrouvé mort
près de sept rivières il a été violée
puis enfouis vivent dans la boue en six
jours l'anc est même à christian
beaulieu un marginal du village qui
passe aux aveux
il est déjà connu pour deux affaires
d'agression sexuelle sur mineur mais il
n'a jamais été suivie par la suite un
raté de la justice que rappelle la
défense c'est une condamnation qui n'est
pas surprenante mais y ait eu beaucoup
de
quand même de laisser aller avant et
pendant vingt ans il a été laissé en
liberté sans qu'on se préoccupe au dha
suivi cette fois la justice a ordonné
que christian beaulieu soit suivi y
compris lit après sa sortie de prison
les experts psychologues considère pour
l'heure que christian beaulieu est un
récidiviste en puissance il restera sous
surveillance jusqu'à la fin de sa vie et
ne devrait pas faire appel de ce verdict
les suites du procès d yvan colonna en
coulisses on prépare son déplacement de
dimanche sur l'île mais malgré cela
l'audience s'est poursuivie devant la
cour d'assises avec l'audition
aujourd'hui d'un homme
l'actuel secrétaire général de l'elysée
claude guéant qui était à l'époque celui
qui coordonnait au ministère de
l'intérieur la traque du berger corse
dominique verdeilhan et jean-marc donc
nook dernier témoin du procès
claude guéant secrétaire général de
l'elysée sans détour avec véhémence des
avocats d'yvan colonna le soupçonne
d'avoir convoqué le commissaire roger
marion avant le procès pour influencer
son témoignage j'ai simplement reçu à sa
demande un ex collaborateur
nous n'avons pas évoqué la faire se
défend claude guéant devant la cour
d'assises
depuis lundi la défense tente de
reprendre l'avantagé pour faire oublier
les points noirs du dossier l'emploi du
temps d' yvan colonna le soir des faits
par exemple j'ai passé la nuit dans ma
bergerie dit l'accusé
les derniers à l'avoir vu ce sont ses
proches à cargèse jusqu'à 20 heures
après plus rien
ces témoignages démontrent que
l'accusation dont il a fait l'objet ne
résiste pas à l'examen
donc pour nous le meilleur alibi de la
dives encore une c'est précisément qui
n'a jamais cherché à se constituer un
alibi un mois d'audience et le sentiment
pour la partie civile que certaines
réponses manquent encore la seule
réponse qu'il devrait être et avoir le
courage de se lever et dire c'est moi
comme les autres l'autre se les autres
au moins ils ont pris leurs
responsabilités ce que je ne supporte
pas dans cette position
c'est la lâcheté madame erignac et ses
enfants ne se rendrons évidemment pas
dimanche à ajaccio un transport de
justice pour voir pour imaginer la scène
du crime yvan colonna lui sera présent
mais comme simple spectateur puisqu'il
encore répété aujourd'hui le 6 février
il n'était pas là fumer nuit gravement à
la santé des personnes on le savait déjà
mais fumer nuit également apparemment au
travail dans l'entreprise
ce sont les pauses cigarettes qui sont
incriminés elle serait facteur de perte
de productivité
alors vrai ou faux éléments de réponse
dans le quartier d'affaires de la
défense à paris avec valérie kg et
delphine parent est mineure la défense
avait sa grande arche et ses gratte ciel
est là aujourd'hui c'est fumeurs par
tous les temps de petite tribu
d'irréductibles s'agglutinent au pied
des tours
peu d'entreprises ont investi dans des
locaux fumeurs préférant jeter les
amateurs de nicotine à la rue à combien
vous faites de prose tabac dans la
journée de deux pauses demain matin est
de pause l'après midi
5 x 5 25 minutes par jour ici fumée se
mérite il faut parfois descendre 30 à 40
étages pour utiliser son briquet c'est
directrice des ressources humaines s'est
livré pour nous un petit calcul en temps
réel alors combien de temps avez vous
mis pour descendre
écoutez six minutes une pause tabac faut
compter à peu près combien de temps à
peu près un bon quart d'heure un quart
d'heure x 4 cela fait une heure par jour
5 heures par semaine c'est beaucoup mais
dans cette entreprise
on préfère miser sur la prévention deux
séminaires ont été organisés pour aider
les salariés volontaires arrêter de
fumer
un fumeur qui ne peut pas fumer sur son
lieu de travail c'est un problème il va
se sentir moins bien il va avoir plus de
mal à se concentrer et c'est donc il
nous a semblé que c'était du rôle de
l'entreprise d'accompagner sa démarche
vers l'arrêt du tabac une dizaine de
sociétés qui veulent rester anonymes ont
fait appel à cet avocat pour négocier
des accords collectifs avec les
syndicats il instaure un temps de pause
supplémentaire pour l'ensemble des
salariés par exemple 15 minutes le matin
et quinze minutes l'après midi ce temps
de pause 30 minutes fait partie
intégrante du temps de travail effectif
des salariés et au delà de 30 minutes
c'est à dire pour les salariés gros
fumeur entre guillemets et bien ce qui
dépasserait 30 minutes de pause et bien
devront rester un peu plus tard le soir
ou venir un peu plus tôt le matin pour
travailler à la même durée que les
autres salariés les salariés non fumeurs
l'interdiction de fumer aurait des
effets positifs sur le dialogue social
combien de contacts se nouent
aujourd'hui autour d'un cendrier
l'avenir des relations entre l'europe et
l'afrique est en discussion ce week-end
à lisbonne au portugal
soixante-dix chefs d'état et de
gouvernement sont attendus au sommet
pour près de prêter de tels thèmes des
droits de l'homme
également du commerce ou encore les
migrations entre l'europe et l'afrique
une question d'immigration qui touche
également les pays africains entre eux
ainsi l'afrique du sud depuis la fin de
l'apartheid doit faire face à un afflux
important d'immigrés clandestins ils
seraient entre 3 et 6 millions
une vague d'immigration que le pays ne
peut absorber reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux dominique derda etc frédéric
guiraud c'est le grand format de ce soir
ils sont près de 500 ce matin tout
zimbabwéen des clandestins renvoyés dans
leur pays à bord d'autocars affrétés par
le ministère de l'intérieur sud afrique
où l'atmosphère est plutôt détendue
beaucoup il est vrai n'en sont pas à
leur premier voyage à chaque fois on
essaie de leur faire comprendre qu'il
ferait mieux de se faire faire un
bizarre d'avoir des papiers en règle et
qu'ensuite seulement il devrait revenir
chez nous mais ça ne sert à rien obtenir
des papiers immigrés légalement facile a
dit il c'est très difficile d'obtenir un
visa et un permis de travail
on essaie mais neuf fois sur dix ça ne
marche pas cette année l'afrique du sud
va expulser environ 240 mille personnes
en situation irrégulière c'est dix fois
plus que la france
puisque à la frontière avec le zimbabwe
six heures de route les autocars holt à
plus de 100 kilomètres heure pas
question de sauter par la plus sur les
bords du limpopo de part et d'autre du
point de passage entre les deux pays
un rideau de fer électrifié
infranchissable mais il suffit d'aller
trois ou quatre kilomètres plus loin et
en quelques minutes à peine même en
plein jour
vous revoilà côté sud afrique franchir
la frontière est vraiment un jeu
d'enfants surtout lorsque la rivière est
à sec il suffit alors de suivre les
traces et de se faufiler comme ici à
travers le grillage à l'époque de
l'apartheid l'afrique du sud ont sans
doute n'avait rien d'un eldorado
depuis l'avènement de la démocratie en
1994 tout a changé
les clandestins seraient entre 3 et 6
millions dans un pays de 44 millions
d'habitants ce n'est pas rien du lundi
matin au vendredi soir au centre de
rétention de l'île d'er là les fourgons
de police se suivent en un flot
ininterrompu
ils viennent de tout le pays
les formalités sont vite expédié d'un
côté les femmes de l'autre les hommes
4000 personnes en moyenne séjourne
salines della en attendant d'être
renvoyés dans leur pays d'origine les
plus nombreux les zimbabwéens et les
mozambicains repartiront par la route
les autres par avion aux frais de la
république sud africaine et tout cela
sans violence
du moins pour autant qu'on puisse en
juger lors d'une visite de quelques
heures
il y a parfois des incidents surtout
lorsque les gens jugent qu'ils ont tout
à perdre si nous les rapatrions alors
oui il arrive qu'ils soient mécontents
et qu'il le montre
mais on essaye de gérer ça de la façon
la plus professionnelle qui soit en
n'oubliant jamais que ce sont des êtres
humains auxquels nous avons atteint la
plupart ne reste ici que quelques
semaines rarement plus de trois mois
c'est la loi qu'il exhibera il arrive
évidemment que certains attendent bien
plus longtemps avant d'être rapatrié
surtout s'ils viennent de loin d'afrique
de l'ouest du nigeria ou bien encore du
congrès cela espère toujours qu'un beau
matin ils seront relâchés ne sont guère
pressés de rentrer au pays environnement
une catastrophe écologique est elle en
cours au large des côtes sud corénne là
bas le pays est en train de connaître la
pire marée noire de son histoire c'est
une barge qui a heurté un pétrolier qui
était l'origine de la catastrophe des
milliers de tonnes de brut se sont déjà
déversés la zone abrite une réserve
maritime retour en france avec le coup
d'envoi du 21e téléthon qui a été donnée
vous l'avez peut-être suivi il ya
quelques minutes sur france 2 là des
milliers de bénévoles sont une nouvelle
fois mobilisé un numéro à retenir tout
au long du week-end le 36 37 4 millions
de personnes sont concernées en france
par les maladies génétiques julie vous
allez le voir fait partie de ces enfants
atteints d'une maladie rare elle a une
force et une envie d'y croire qu'ils
nous obligent à réfléchir et à agir au
portage youki vattier didier colas les
histoires de fées de sorcières ça et
comme toujours couche comme une star
mais je vais la raconter
je m'appelle 19/20 et genia maman qui
s'appelle de cristal à papa qui
s'appelle le lorrain il n'y petit
ressort qui s'appelle laura puis à
saint-amand laissé dans une histoire
c'est ma famille est sûre siens il y en
a qu une seule mais très grave et c'est
la maladie c'est comme maléfique dans la
belle au bois dormant
mais sauf que là c'est la savane
amyotrophie spinale pareil au niveau de
la prise en charge soit la kiné la
verticalisation vous appareil
respiratoire elle accepte tout pour que
ça se passe pas trop mal pour elle et là
ça se traduit par à dire un emploi du
talent de sportif de haut niveau c'est
un combat physique en 3d comme à la
guerre c'est plus d'un gang band l on en
a marre de faire marche et ça
des fois on n'en a pas trop de
ressources pour des choses comme âge pas
du tout peur ce qu'on veut tout le temps
de manger chercher le pain riz
absolument peur que je tends de quoi
manger papa concentre
on m'aide beaucoup un supporter la
maladie tous à l'investiture moins pas
en fait ce que je vois pas trop en quoi
dire si sûr mais si je me rends mon
coeur j'ai simplement marcher la vie si
tu me regarde à la télé dis toi bien que
joue pas mon resto voilà et n'oubliez
pas le 36 37
un sapin pour noël mais à quel prix le
symbole incontournable des fêtes de fin
d'année est arrivée dans les magasins et
la première information et qu'il faudra
peut-être dépenser un peu plus cette
année encore pour décorer la maison
alors justement comment se calcule le
prix d'un sapin exploitants revendeurs
qui s'y trouvent le mieux c'est le
reportage de séverine lebrun et de
marica zone tout est question de rythme
des centaines de sapins sont à livrer
dans la journée c'est la pleine saison
mais d'ici le travail a commencé il y a
des mois une production qui coûte cher
il faut près de dix ans avant qu'un
sapin soit commercialisables et encore
sur les quarante cinq mille pièces
plantés chaque année la moitié finir à
la poubelle
il ya la perte à la reprise la perte
pendant la végétation et soit des dégâts
de chevreuils des dégâts de gel et de 15
personnes ce salarié à plein temps pour
un travail entièrement fait à la main un
plan acheté un euro cinquante à
l'origine sera vendu par ce producteur
12 euros pour des sapins de taille
moyenne comme ceux ci par exemple
touche les armes après si cette fois et
à chaque fois qu'on touche chez du temps
et voilà c'est tout ça c'est à rajouter
mon premier temps nous retrouvons notre
sapin en grandes surfaces ils coûtent
presque deux fois plus cher
22h50 regard des 4,5 malgré les clients
hésitent peu le sapin de noël est un
incontournable qu'est l'eau d'heure
quand on arrive à la raison et puis
c'est une tradition donc les gens font
un peu de sacrifices pour les fêtes
y'a pas de prix dix ans pour que mon
fils ait des yeux tout et baïse
chaque année 6 millions de sapins sont
bondues on les retrouve dans près d'un
foyer français sur quatre une nouvelle
cliente hermes pour les constructeurs
français de bateaux l'asie
particulièrement la chine sont en train
de s'éveiller dans ce secteur des
clients nouveaux ou pouvoir d'achat
important
les spécialistes estiment entre 5 et 10
millions le nombre d'acheteurs
potentiels désormais et les bateaux à
voile aurait leur préférence julien momo
et chloé cormery
des invités de marque une vie privée en
version originale normal monsieur mineta
a fait plus de dix mille kilomètres pour
venir acheter ce voilier
car le salon de paris avec ses 200
nouveautés exposées en première mondiale
at il une large clientèle
je possède le même en plus petit et sur
le nouveau j'adore le design et en plus
ça nous permet d'être très performant
sur l'eau un marché asiatique en plein
boom
à côté des bateaux traditionnels voilà
ce que l'on commence à croiser sur les
plans d'eau des voiliers français et
même des régates
une première pour ces deux spectateurs
chinois ils n'ont pas 40 ans mais ils
sont déjà millionnaire l'un fait fortune
dans l'internet l'autre dans le fret
maritime
une passion commune la voile quand nous
le voilier ça veut dire vacansoleil
propos en fait c'est un style de vie à
l'occidentale c'est très prisé ici
exemple avec cette marina tout neuf à
shenzhen hong kong
l'avic souvent dans le secteur ce magnat
de l'industrie a vu ce port se remplir à
vitesse grand v ya un an et demi son il
n'y avait rien et regardez aujourd'hui
c'est presque plein olivier dès qu'on
connaît bien le marché chinois
vingt ans qu'ils vont des voiliers ici
les chinois adorent le golfe dès qu'ils
ont un peu d'argent ils vont s'inscrire
au golf ensuite ils vont acheter une
grosse voiture ont montré leur richesse
et je pense que l'étape suivante sur les
bateaux de plaisance en 2007 la chine
compte 100 milliardaires en dollars
ils n'étaient que 15 l'an dernier le
marché de la plaisance suit la même
évolution pour l'instant les ventes ne
représentent que 5% du marché mondial
mais les volumes double chaque année par
le mode avec christian lacroix qui a
créé l'exposition de ses rêves c'est en
piochant dans les réseaux
du musée de la mode à paris et dans ses
propres collections que le couturier a
choisi de nous raconter son histoire de
la mode
visite guidée avec estelle colin et
tristan le braz propulsé au rang de
superstar christian lacroix fut sacré
couturier alors qu'enfant il se rêvait
conservateurs de musées de cette
vocation est née son goût du métissage
de ces ménages d'affluence les mariés
d'une manière était rouge jusque à la
fin du xviiie début du 19ème parce que
c'était la couleur la plus difficile
obtenue vente la plus chère point de
rétrospective pour cette exposition jugé
trop prétentieux nous l'idée de jouer
les archéologues et décrypté trois
cycles de monde cette robe 1930 avec
sever et ce rouge après faire trés noël
ça ne l'est pas on voit aussi sa robe
18e la jaune quand même insensé la
manière dont elle est encore fraîche et
ses vitrines là pour moi c'est comme un
étalage de pâte d'amande a tellement
content on a tellement fait d'avoir
cette coulée de de choc ça devient
énorme
chaque vendredi durant un ami christian
lacroix s'est plongé dans la malle aux
trésors les réserves du musée cent
trente mille pièces passé au crible avec
gourmandise
rien ne lui fait peur parce qu'une fois
qu'on avait terminé de regarder les
vêtements il a voulu regarder des
chaffauds ça c'est à nouveau à peu près
peut-être 3000 pièces à regarder quand
on avait affiné regarder les chapeaux il
aurait voulu regarder les broderies
alors là c'est exponentiel vient ça ne
s'arrête pas au final 400 vêtements
servent de décors vous vous exactement 2
comme les esters bralo 80 créations
haute couture d'un christian lacroix
entre anti sorcier souvent quand
j'arrive là je me dis mais si on avait
mis devant tout ça à quand tu avais dix
ans et c'était vraiment on t'a raison
d'être et de vivre très mort de plaisir
pour moi pas ressorti vivant plusieurs
siècles se sait lui impossible d'adapter
toutes ses créations paris donc réussi
pour un couturier qui adore brouiller
les pistes
une image maintenant celle de la statue
la plus chère au cm² cette culture de
seulement 8 cm de haut a été adjugé 57
millions de dollars par la maison
sotheby's à new york
tous les plus grands musées du monde
espérait acquérir mais c'est un amateur
d'art britannique qui l'a emporté la
statue connu sous le nom de l'yonne de
guénels d'attrait d'au moins cinq mille
ans avant de refermer journal je vous
rappelle cette information prudence
mes espoirs en colombie avec la
proposition du président uribe de créer
une zone de rencontre pour négocier avec
la guérilla des farc les échanges
d'otages contre des rebelles emprisonnés
parmi ces otages bien évidemment ingrid
betancourt les autorités françaises et
le comité de soutien de l'otage franco
colombienne y souhaitent se soit rester
extrêmement prudent face à cette avancée
voilà pour l'actualité de ce vendredi
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal je vous
retrouve dès demain à 13h pour le
journal et pour le magazine 13h15 ou 5
dans un instant la météo il nouvelle
martinez suivi du point route de valérie
maurice à 20h50 votre soirée polar
ensuite vers 23h30 ne manquez pas le
téléthon 2007 en direct depuis le
château de vincennes belle soirée à vous
et à demain
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr
autre soi